so for those of you who've been keeping
up with e3 you will have seen at the
lace installment of Assassin's Creed is
set in ancient Greece and is called
Odyssey a term that is often used to
describe a long live in full journey if
you are somewhat familiar of Greek
mythology then you also know that it's a
piece of work by the Greek poet Homer
which describes the tales and many
voyages of the Greek hero Odysseus after
the sack of Troy now this is quite
interesting because we are told that
Assassin's Creed Odyssey will take place
during the Peloponnesian War a war where
Athens and Sparta battled for control of
Greece a Battle of chaos and democracy
in this video I'll be recapping what was
mentioned by Ubisoft and making some
predictions on what we might see in the
game so in game you have a choice of two
characters either the male protagonist
Alexius or the female cassandra
whichever one of these two that you
choose it still seems that you played
the grandchild of the spartan king
leonidas with his broken spear being
your primary weapon now after seeing
what was done with Assassin's Creed
origins and their integration of the
Egyptian Pantheon I was eagerly awaiting
to see if they were delve into Greek
mythology with Odyssey and boy do they
not hold back on their references the
gameplay in cinematics that we were
shown were absolutely littered with
statues of heroes and gods ranging from
Zeus and Poseidon to Artemis and Athena
the character you play is even said to
bear the eagle of Zeus so I do think
that will be seen the Greek gods in some
shape or form which means for those of
you who have been craving more Greek
mythology since god of war or does he
may be the game for you now just based
on what we were shown at e3 it's very
difficult to gauge how the Greek gods
will feature my guess is that if we do
see the Greek gods it'll be quite
similar to the Trojan War where there
were gods on either side influencing the
outcome Athena being the patron deity of
Athens will of course side of the
Athenians perhaps even be in your
fiercest opposition now I'm sure quite a
few people would expect the patron god
of Sparta and the natural rival of
Athena to be Ares but the god that the
Spartans worshipped as their patron was
not actually a god but rather the
goddess Artemis which is why I believe
in the trailer we do see a fair amount
of animals being hunted
artemis of course was the goddess most
renowned for the hunt along with a giant
statue of autumn us we are showing one
more thing that may hint us in further
interaction with the goddess in one of
the traders that will be in shown we do
see some kind of stag or deer perhaps
being hunted we don't really get to see
this animal in too much detail because
of the Sun in the back but there is a
chance of this animals the ceranae and
her
for those of you who have somewhat
unfamiliar the ceranae in hind was a
huge and agile dear sacred to the
goddess Artemis and it's captures one of
the twelve labors of Heracles so I think
there is a chance as some kind of quest
or even a task to prove yourself to
Artemis that you'll be attempting to
capture this beast during the
Peloponnesian War itself both Athens and
Sparta made an appeal to the Persians
for help but none was given the Spartans
then chose to attack Persian occupied
states and eventually invaded Africa in
the year 431 BC which is when the game
is set so judging by what we've briefly
seen they're most likely be some kind of
Persian and African influences in the
game I'm not entirely sure if we're
going to see any of the heroes or
demigods as Heracles is mentioned and we
do see a statue of Perseus but I would
personally prefer to see some of the
lesser mentioned heroes such as
Bellerophon or even Jason I know like
myself a lot of people would have been
waiting to see the iconic creatures and
monsters and then it'd make us wait
right until the end when we see the back
of a creature that looks an awfully lot
like a Minotaur seeing the Minotaur is
definitely a good sign that there'll be
more monsters and creatures I'd be very
surprised if they just included the
Minotaur with so many great options
available in fact I do believe we get a
snapshot of what appears to be Medusa
which I expect is quite different to
what most people imagined we're told
much like Homer's Odyssey a portion of
this game we spent at sea so I expect to
either come across Plato's lost city of
Atlantis or maybe Scylla and many of the
other sea monsters and deities so now
you've heard some of my theories of what
we could possibly see in the game I
guess it's time for my overall opinion
and what we were shown I did see a lot
of people complaining about how Odyssey
looks like a reskin version of
Assassin's Creed origins and for the
most part I can see with some of these
people coming from if we're being honest
most people were going to play this game
because of the setting because of the
allure of Greek mythology and the
possibility of fighting against the
Greek pantheon one thing however that
did stick out to me was the accents that
we see in the game there are some fairly
okay Greek accents that we will shown
but there are also some really really
bad middle-eastern accents that are
meant to be Greek I guess and then we
have some British accents thrown in
there for good measure so I'm not sure
what they're going with but it does kind
of break the immersion of the whole game
overall I'm definitely excited to see
more of the game which creatures on
which gods that integrate into it and
how they approach Greek mythology as a
whole if you did manage to catch the
Assassin's Creed Odyssey reveal then let
me know how you felt about it
the only thing in particular that
excited you or was there something that
you just didn't like let me know in the
comments below
[Music]